after months of speculation the US
President Joe Biden has confirmed to Sky
News that he will stand for re-election
next year an official announcement is
expected tomorrow let's get more from
our U.S correspondent Mark stone at the
White House
it must be the most anticipated
announcement in Washington uh for for
quite some time will he won't he the
speculation has been that he wants to
seek a second term that he wants to run
again he said before Christmas that he
would uh count he would get the Council
of his own family he would ask his wife
Jill Biden the first lady whether or not
she believed he should run again of
course against him at his age he's 80
years old he would be 82 at time at the
time of re-election and he would be near
a 90 at the end of the second term if he
was to be successful he'll be aware of
the polls too just one in four Americans
believe that he should run again
according to the latest NBC polling but
I was in the Rose Garden just now at an
event for teachers for Education
something close to his heart and indeed
to his wife's heart she is a teacher and
I asked him just as he headed back into
the Oval Office uh will you run again
have a listen
were you gonna run again
you might need to be a lip reader um but
I can assure you he said yes one word uh
are you going to run against uh and he's
a reply quite clearly uh yes uh which to
me is a change from just what he was
saying moments earlier when he said I've
told you before my intention is uh to
run again
um so uh we will find out for sure
probably tomorrow certainly this week
the expectation is that a it will be in
the form of a video release we
understand that some of it was was
filmed quite recently uh uh uh putting
together a video release that will be
very similar to the one that we saw four
years ago when he sought the presidency
for the first time around I imagine or
certainly our understanding is that much
of the messaging uh will be uh will be
the same it will be a battle for the
soul of the nation as he as he has
called it so many times before and he
will uh we we understand say that he
wants to get the job done to finish the
job that he has spent the past four
years doing but as I say his approval
rating is not good